>> ALRIGHT.
AFTER THIS GIANT MESS IN
AFGHANISTAN, WHAT IS THE
RESPONSE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE?
BOY DID WE SCREW UP, BUT LOOK A
HOW WE FIXED UP A TALK ABOUT FIX
, THIS IS A MESS SO SCREWED
UP IT WILL HAVE REVERBERATIONS
FOR MANY YEARS WHICH MEANS THE
PERSON RESPONSIBLE PROBABLY
WON'T SEE THE END RESULT SPIRIT
STILL THE WHITE HOUSE WILL SAY
LOOK AT THIS HUMANITARIAN FEAT
OF STRENGTH.
IT'S MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN JOE
PROTECTIONIST FROM CORN POP
APPEARED WE GOT OUT 100,000 PLU
PEOPLE FOR THE DEADLINE THE
TALIBAN WANT TOO.
SPIRIT AIRLINE HAS NOTHING ON US
.
IT'S A WEIRD CONTRAST WE'RE
EVACUATING THOUSANDS OF AFGHANS
ON THE OTHER YOU SAY THEY
TALIBAN HAS CHANGED, SO WHY IS
EVERYONE FLEEING IF THEY'VE
CHANGED?
DO WE HAVE ANYTHING TO FEAR FRO
THE TALIBAN OTHER THAN THEIR
FASHION SENSE?
THEIR NEW AND IMPROVED LIKE THE
APACHE HELICOPTER WE LEFT BEHIN
GREAT I'M SURE THEY JUST BAND
MUSIC IN KILLED A FOLKSINGER
IT'S THE TERROR VERSION OF
FOOTLOOSE.
I GUESS THEY PREFER THEIR SONS
TO COME FROM GOATS.
OUR THINGS CHANGING?
CHECK OUT THIS ANCHORMAN READIN
THE NEWS SPIRIT THE TALIBAN
SENSORS DON'T EVEN BOTHER TO
STAND OFF-CAMERA.
YOU CAN TELL THE ANGER IS REALL
LOOKING FORWARD TO A BRIGHT
FUTURE UNDER HIS NEW LEADERS.
HERE'S A TIP, DON'T PLAY ANY
MUSIC.
THIS ISN'T CNN WHERE WHEN YOU
SCREW UP YOU GET A VACATION.
I'M NOT ONE TO POINT FINGERS, O
AM I?
>> GREG POINTS THE FINGER.
STARTING FINGERS.
>> IT'S TIME ONCE AGAIN TO POIN
FINGERS STRAIGHT AFTER ALL,
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THEM.
THAT SOY THE HUMANS ARE IN
CHARGE INSTEAD OF SEALS.
THEY DON'T HAVE FINGERS, EMILY.
THEY HAVE FINS.
PEOPLE SAY GREAT, IT'S TOO SOON
FOR THAT.
THAT SO THEY SAID ABOUT THE
PREMIERE OF THE SHOW, AND I
DIDN'T LISTEN.
IF WE DON'T CALL OUT THE BS, WH
WILL?
THINK OF ALL THE GREAT FINGER
POINTERS IN HISTORY.
SO DID EVERY MEMBER OF THE FOUR
TOPS.
YOUR MOM AT THE AQUARIUM.
LOOK AT, A WHALE, A WHALE.
EVERY DOCTOR ABOUT TO DO A
CROSSFIT EXAM.
LET'S NOT FORGET EVERYONE'S
FAVORITE ALIEN, THAT'S RIGHT, H
POINTED A FINGER.
AND WHAT OF UNCLE SAM, A A GREA
FINGER POINTER IN OF COURSE THE
GREATEST FINGER POINTER OF ALL,
GOD SO BACK TO THIS MESSAGE.
YOU ONLY DESERVE CREDIT IF YOU
DO A THOROUGH JOB OF CLEANING I
UP.
IF YOU LEFT HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS LEFT BEHIND, YOU
DIDN'T CLEAN IT UP.
IT'S LIKE HOW A GUY CLEANS UP
AFTER AN ALL-NIGHT POKER GAME.
YOU THROUGHOUT THE BEER BOTTLES
AND PIZZA BOXES INTO YOUR GOOD
CAN BE USED OFF TO GET THE
STAINS OUT OF THE RUG BEFORE
YOUR WIFE GETS HOME OR AT LEAST
MOVE THE SOFA OVERWRITES.
THIS ISN'T NITPICKING, THIS IS
ABOUT AMERICAN LIVES GREAT IF
YOU LEFT IT BEHIND, YOU'VE GOT
TO FIX IT.
MAY BE OUR GOVERNMENT IS IN NOT
TELLING HIS, BUT CONSIDER THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE, THE ONES WHO
HAVE A HISTORY OF SNATCHING
DEFEAT FROM THE JAWS OF VICTORY.
NO ONE'S BLAMING THE TROOPS WHO
DON'T MAKE THE DECISIONS IN OUR
IN GINGER WE ARE BLAMING THE
POLITICIANS WHO MADE THE
DECISION IN WENT ON VACATION.
MEANWHILE, THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE MEDIA WILL REDEFINE YOUR
OUTRAGE AS DIRECTED AGAINST THE
MILITARY.
IF YOUR MAD ABOUT THE DISASTROU
PULLOUT, JOE PRETEND YOU'RE MAD
THAT WE'RE ENDING THE WAR, HIS
ENTIRE SPEECH WAS BAIT AND
SWITCH GREAT I LOVE HOW HE BRAG
ABOUT THE WITHDRAWAL WHILE ALSO
BLAMING TRUMP.
SO IT'S A SUCCESS ELICITS A
FAILURE, AND THEN THAT'S ON
TRUMP.
THE DECISION MADE BY TRUMP IS
PRETTY SOUND, IT'S A BIDENS
FOLLOW-THROUGH THAT WERE MAD
ABOUT.
WE'RE NOT MAD AT THE MILITARY
EXCEPT FOR GENERALS PUSHING WOK
MYTHS WHILE SAYING THE TALIBAN
HAS CHANGED.
WE'RE UPSET WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LIKE A DRUNK
HIKER LOST IN THE WOODS, CHOSE
THE WORST POSSIBLE PATH IN PUT
EVERYONE AT RISK.
LOOKING BACK IT TAKES A SPECIFI
GENIUS TO TAKE THAT MANY
MISTAKES.
IT'S LIKE FLIPPING A COIN AND
GETTING HEADS 100 TIMES IN A ROW
, HOW CAN YOU BE THAT
CONSISTENT?
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR THINGS TO G
WRONG THIS PERFECTLY UNLESS IT
WAS IN THE PLAN.
YOU ABANDONED AIR BASE, YOU WIL
HAND OVER UP PILE OF WEAPONRY
MAKING THE TALIBAN BETTER ARMED
THAN THE NRA BRADY OF A
PRESIDENT TELLING US EVERYTHING
WILL BE FINE, KNOCK ON WOOD.
KNOCK ON WOOD, ONLY IF YOU CAN
FIND JOHN KERRY'S FACE.
TALK ABOUT DRASTIC ESCALATION I
A USE OF KNOCK ON WOOD.
USUALLY I SAY THAT FOR HOPING
THE CAFETERIA STILL HAD SOUP.
THEN YOU SEE AFGHANS FALLING
FROM PLANES, BUT THAT WAS FIVE
DAYS AGO, REMEMBER THAT.
SO 100 TIMES SHORTER THAN RUSSI
GATE.
THEN WE GIVE A LIST OF AMERICAN
TO THE TALIBAN, I'M STILL UNSUR
WHAT THAT MEANS, BUT I DOUBT
THEY'RE GOING TO BECOME PENPALS.
AND WE GET 13 DEAD FROM A
HOMICIDAL BUMMER.
WHO WAS CHECKING THAT BOMBER IN?
WAS IT THE TALIBAN?
IT MATTERS WHEN YOU HEAR THEY
OFFERED CONTROL TO BIDEN WHO
DECLINED IT.
HE PROBABLY THOUGHT I CAN'T
CONTROL MY EYELIDS, HOWEVER MY
GOING TO CONTROL IN AIRPORT.
YOU WANTED THE TALIBAN TO HAVE
MORE CONTROL OF AFGHANISTAN THE
THE TALIBAN WANTED.
IN THEN, AS THE CAPTIVES OF OUR
DEAD WE'RE UNLOADED FROM A PLANE
, JOE BIDEN CHECKED HIS
BOSS WATCH.
IS SUDDENLY IN A HURRY.
I WON'T POINT ANY FINGERS HERE,
BECAUSE IF I WERE JOE BIDEN, I'
BE CHECKING MY WATCH TO, HOW
MUCH LONGER DO I HAVE TO DO THI
JOB HE'S WONDERING?
BELIEVE ME, SO ARE WE.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT GUESTS.
SHE TALKS FASTER THAN AN
AUCTIONEER WHO HAS TO PEAK,
EMILY COMPAGNO.
THE BUCK STOPS HERE, AND HE
BROUGHT HIS HAIR, RADIO HOST
BUCK SEXTON.
HE'S GOT A FACE FOR RADIO AND A
SPOT FOR THE BLIND.
JIMMY FAILLA.
AND, SHE IS LIKE LANCE ARMSTRONG
, REALLY SUCCESSFUL,
BUT CHEATS ON DRUG TESTS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
I'M GOING TO YOU FIRST, BUCK
BECAUSE YOU SERVED IN THE CIA I
AFGHANISTAN AND YOUR HAIR SERVE
IN NAM, RIGHT?
>> TRUE.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
BOTCHED BOTCHED WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT?
>> WE'RE SAYING IT'S BODS NOT
BECAUSE IT IS AND WE SOUGHT AND
THEY COULDN'T HIDE IT FROM US.
IN PART BECAUSE THE TALIBAN
DOESN'T HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY OR
THE ABILITY TO SHUT DOWN.
PEOPLE WERE TEXTING ME IN REAL
TIME ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON ON
THE GROUND THERE.
SO WE SAW WHAT A MESS IT WAS.
IT WAS CLEARLY NOT PLANNED.
BUT JUST GIVE THIS A FEW DAYS
BECAUSE NOW THAT WE ARE AT THE
POINT WHERE WERE AT, THERE IS
STILL 100 PLUS AMERICANS ON THE
GROUND, THE NARRATIVE IS GOING
TO SWITCH VERY QUICKLY TO JOE
BIDEN IS THE GUY THAT GOT THING
DONE.
HE'S THE ONE THAT MADE THE TOUG
CALL HERE IN THE FACT THAT THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT 300,000
PERSON PLUS ARMY THAT EVAPORATED
, THAT WE LOST
SOLDIERS IN AFGHANISTAN, WILL B
QUICKLY FORGOTTEN, BUT THEY'VE
ALREADY STARTED TO USE BLIPS ON
CNN ABOUT THE INSURRECTION
COMMISSION.
NOW THEY ARE SUBPOENAING THE
TRUMP FAMILY RECORDS.
THEY'RE MOVING PAST IT AS
QUICKLY IMPOSSIBLE.
IT WILL BE GUEST LIKING ON MOTH
LEVEL SCALE.
>> YOU WERE IN THE CIA, HOW DID
WE GET, I LOVE THE FACT THAT JO
BIDEN WILL GET THE ACCOLADES
AFTER BEING A VP FOR EIGHT YEAR
WHILE PRESIDING OVER AFGHANISTAN
, BUT WHY WAS THE
INTELLIGENCE SO WRONG?
>> THE PEOPLE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WHO TELL
THOSE IN CHARGE WHAT THEY WANT
TO HEAR ARE THE ONES WHO GET
THEY KEEP TALKING TO PEOPLE IN
CHARGE, THE ONES THAT GET INTO
THE OVAL OFFICE, THE ONES THAT
ARE IN FRONT OF THE TV REGULARLY
, IT'S LIKE ANY OTHER
BUREAUCRACY OR THE KISSERS GET
PROMOTED AND MOVE UP AND PEOPLE
OFTEN FEEL LIKE THEY CAN'T
HANDLE IT AND LEAVE AND GET ON
LATE 19 VP.
>> WAS AT A JAB AT YOUR OWN SELF
?
>> SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, IT'S LIKE
INSIDE EVERY MASSIVE MAJOR
PROJECT, YOU NEED TO MAKE IT
SOUND LIKE IT'S GOING WELL,
EMILY, SO THEY DON'T STOP THE
PROJECT, SO YOU FIND DATA THAT
SUPPORTS IT, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY
SABOTAGED 27 HUMVEES, THEY DON'
TELL YOU THEY WERE 27,000 OF
THEM OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHERE DOES YOUR BRAIN REST AT
THIS POINT?
>> BOTTOM LINE, WE HAVE A
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WHO ABANDONE
AMERICAN SPIRIT ABANDON ALLIES,
AND ORPHANS AND WOMEN IN WORKIN
DOGS TO MEET AN ARBITRARY
DEADLINE THAT HE SET.
HE SURRENDERED ALL OF THESE
LIVES, AND LIKE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF EQUIPMENT TO
THE TALIBAN AND HAVE THE
AUDACITY TO DO A VICTORY LAP
TODAY.
THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER THAT YOU
CREATED.
HE BLAMES EVERYONE ELSE ON THE
PLANET, BUT HIMSELF INCLUDING
OUR AFGHAN ALLIES U.S. 66,000 O
THEIR OWN PEOPLE ALONGSIDE OUR
2500.
IN THEN SPEAKING OF WATCH, AS
YOU POINTED OUT, HE CHECKS HIS
WATCH EACH TIME A COFFIN COMES
OUT OF THE PLANE DURING A
DIGNIFIED TRANSFER.
AND WE ARE SUPPOSED TO THINK
THAT HE HAS A MODICUM OF
RESPONSIBILITY NEEDED TO HOLD
THIS OFFICE?
TO ME ON THIS FINAL DAY OF A 20
YEAR WAR, OTHER THAN ENDLESS
GRATITUDE FOR EVERYONE WHO
SERVED, AND HONORING EVERY LIFE
WHO WAS SACRIFICED WHO DID NOT
DIE IN VAIN DURING THOSE 20
YEARS, I PERSONALLY FEEL NOTHING
, BUT ASHAMED THAT THAT
PERSON IS MY PRESIDENT.
>> STRONG EMOTIONS.
JIMMY, YOUR JACKET IS ALMOST AS
BAD AS THE WITHDRAWAL.
I LIKE HOW YOU MATCHED YOUR
SHOES WITH IT.
>> I COMMITTED.
>> WHERE IS THE ICE CREAM TRUCK?
>> AROUND THE BLOCK.
>> YOU DIDN'T TELL ME BIDEN WAS
GOING TO BE HERE.
>> I FEEL LIKE ON SOME LEVEL YO
GUYS ARE BEING A LITTLE HARSH T
JOE BIDEN, OTHER THAN HE'S DOIN
A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
OTHER THAN EVERYTHING IN THE
COUNTRY, THE GUY HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB.
THIS IS EMBARRASSING AND THE
BRAZEN NATURE IN WHICH THEY LIE
TO THE PUBLIC, IT REALLY DOES
BOTHER ME BECAUSE ON SOME LEVEL
THEY ARE TALKING TO US IS IF WE
WILL FORGET, AND THERE DOING IT
WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE
MEDIA IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
THERE FOR THEM AND WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT THE MEDIA DID TRY
TO CREATE SOME DISTANCE BETWEEN
THEMSELVES AND THIS BECAUSE IT
WAS HORRIFIC, BUT IT DIDN'T STO
THEM FROM DOING WHAT THEY DO.
JEN PSAKI GETS OUT THERE EVERY
DAY.
IF SHE WAS ON THE PRICE SHE
WOULD CLAIM THE ICEBERG WAS PAR
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
EVACUATION WENT FINE.
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
>> AND THERE'S NO PRECONDITIONS
WITH THE ICEBERG.
>> RIGHT.
>> I'M GOING TO STOP THAT JOKE
THERE.
>> YOU WERE SAYING THIS EARLIER
ABOUT THE HAVE IT BOTH WAYS
MENTALITY.
ONE END ONCE YOU DO BELIEVE IT
SUCCESSFUL, ON THE OTHER END HE
WANTED TO BELIEVE THIS IS WHAT
TRUMP DID.
IF THAT IS TO BE THE CASE YOU
HAVE TO CHECK AMOUNT IS FOR IT
AND HE HAS RESCINDED EVERY ONE
OF DONALD TRUMP'S POLICIES
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER, WHY IS
THIS THE ONE POLICY HE KEPT IF
IT WAS SO BAD.
HE SCREWED THIS UP.
JOE BIDEN SUCKS, BOTTOM LINE.
>> THAT IS SUCH A GREAT POINT.
JIMMY JUST EXCEEDED EMILY ON
REDMEAT POINTS BY SAYING THAT.
I'M GLAD THAT HOT TOPIC WAS OVE
TODAY AND YOU WERE ABLE TO GET
YOUR OUTFIT.
>> I LOOK SO GOOD.
I LOOK REALLY REALLY GOOD.
>> I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR, IT
WAS FOREVER 31.
YOU LOOK AMAZING.
>> JIMMY, YOU'RE RIGHT, YOU'RE
FAR MORE ATTRACTIVE THAN I AM.
>> THAT IS A DEBATE WE NEED TO
BE HAVING.
YOU'RE SLIGHTLY MORE ATTRACTIV
THAN JIMMY.
WE ARE NOT AIRING THIS EPISODE.
>> BUT THAT WAS SO GOOD ASIDE
FROM HOW BREATHTAKINGLY
ATTRACTIVE I AM, THIS IS
HORRIBLE, THE WHOLE SPEECH WAS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN'T
NATIONBUILDING WHICH IS
SOMETHING I AGREE WITH, BUT IT'
ALSO SOMETHING THAT I'VE ALWAYS
BELIEVED WHICH IS VERY OPPOSITE
TO JOE BIDEN'S DECADES LONG
CAMPAIGN FOR NATIONBUILDING.
I AGREE WITH BUCKET, I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE A COUPLE OF PEOPLE
GET FIRED BECAUSE WE CAN'T
NATIONBUILDING, IT DOESN'T WORK
WE KNEW THAT SOONER THAN 20
YEARS, SO WHO ARE ALL THE
YES-MEN THAT HEADS ABOVE THESE
DEFENSE COMPANIES COME WITH HER
ON TV TELLING US WHAT WE SHOULD
DO, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM GE
FIRED IN WE CANCELED PEOPLE FOR
LITERALLY EVERYTHING ELSE EXCEP
STUFF THAT REALLY MATTERS.
>> EVERY SENIOR LEVEL MILITARY
IN BUREAUCRATS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I TALKED IT WAS LIKE
WE FIGURED IT OUT.
WE GOT IT.
WE KNOW THE NEXT 12 MONTHS AND
EVERY PERSON WE TALKED TO WAS O
THEIR FIFTH TOUR OR THEIR
SEVENTH TOUR, AND KNEW THE
COUNTRY SAID NO CHANCE.
NO CHANCE.
THAT WAS A DECADE AGO.
>> THAT IS DEPRESSING WHEN YOU